what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today um i've
been on a run of like early 2000's music
videos so i'm gonna be reacting to baby
bash
cyclo
when i was in high school this this was
the [ __ ] so i'm i'm excited before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos let's go
[Music]
wow that girl is
flexible clearly you see her hips my
hips do not move like
[Music]
[Music]
like natural bodies like
do you see this this doesn't look like a
crazy butt to hip weight great waist
ratio this looks so normal
like obviously attractive in shape but
nothing like the crazy stuff you see
today
[Music]
the way she move her body she might see
the maserati she wanna put it homie
trying to show me her tsunami
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
okay so just you guys know he's saying
she moves her body like a cyclone
so i'm guessing that like a cyclone can
move in a sexual way because that's how
she's moving and that makes him want to
do her all night
[Music]
like
[Music]
[Music]
she got her own labels
[Music]
i think he might be talking about
strippers
i'm just putting two and two together
now
[Music]
so they
[Music]
drop it down
i wonder if the girls in these music
videos are like someone's mom now
[Music]
i'm so glad i never put anything like
this out there
maybe like a couple drunk pictures in
college
but nothing crazy nothing where like my
butt is completely on the internet or
anything like this
like a cyclone
[Music]
me
okay
all right guys
um clearly that's a fire song five out
of five
i know i've been given a lot of fives
lately
it's because it's i've listened to a lot
of fire lately i don't know what you
want me to say
um anyways
thank you for watching don't forget to
subscribe i'll talk to you guys next
time